digamos que aquí tenemos una compañía
que tiene exactamente cuatro acciones
exactamente cuatro acciones simplemente
para mantener sencillas las cosas
realmente hay muy pocas compañías que
tengan sólo cuatro acciones pero eso lo
hacemos para simplificar nuestra
explicación y ahora vamos a decir que
cada una de estas acciones va a valer o
al menos en la última transacción en el
mercado esas acciones se cotizaron en
dos dólares por acción dos dólares por
acción así que el mercado está indicando
que cada una de estas acciones vale dos
dólares tenemos cuatro acciones en total
por lo que asumiendo que esa compañía no
tiene ningún tipo de pasivo es decir que
los accionistas son dueños de los
activos entonces cuatro de estas
acciones por dos dólares el mercado
indica que los activos de esta compañía
valen exactamente ocho dólares aquí
escribimos ocho dólares el valor en el
mercado de los activos vale ocho dólares
debido a que no tenemos ningún pasivo
ahora quiero que pensemos en qué sucede
si la compañía quiere
y recabar más dinero digamos que ellos
quieren generar más acciones para
venderlas y poder obtener dinero para
comprar una fábrica lo que hacen
literalmente es que el consejo directivo
aprueba que se creen dos acciones más
dos acciones más por lo que ahora
tendremos en el mercado un total de seis
acciones y entonces esta compañía recibe
una inversión bancaria una oferta
secundaria y venden estas acciones
incrementales y las pueden vender
digamos para mantener esto simple que
las venden a dos dólares cada acción
normalmente cuando incrementamos la
cantidad de acciones no se obtiene lo
que se obtenía en las ventas previas
pero aquí vamos a decir que las vendimos
en dos dólares por acción y el haber
vendido estas dos acciones por dos
dólares la compañía pudo recabar otros
cuatro dólares
y la razón por la que estoy haciendo
este ejercicio es para hacerles una
pregunta se está diluyendo la empresa se
está diluyendo hay diferentes maneras de
pensar en esto una manera es como
ustedes pueden imaginarse al escuchar la
palabra diluir si tienen un jarabe dulce
y le agregan agua el conjunto se volverá
menos dulce ya que cada gota de este
jarabe al mezclarse con el agua se
diluirá y será menos dulce y pareciera
que tenemos una analogía aquí ahora
tenemos más secciones para la misma
compañía y es cierto si ustedes fueran
el dueño de esta acción de aquí antes de
que se ofrecieran en el mercado estas
dos acciones ustedes serían dueños del
25 por ciento de la compañía después de
que salieron esas acciones adicionales
ahora son dueños de una sexta parte de
la empresa en lugar de una cuarta parte
después ustedes son dueños de
aproximadamente el 16 por ciento que es
menor al 25% anterior el porcentaje del
que ustedes eran dueños se ha diluido
pero a veces el término de diluir tiene
otro tipo de significado ya que se
tienen más acciones para
dueños de la misma compañía y quizás
estas acciones ahora ya valen menos esto
es algo que quiero que vean se está
diluyendo el porcentaje en el que
ustedes son dueños de la compañía pero
el valor de las acciones no se está
diluyendo porque si antes teníamos
cuatro acciones que representaban el
valor de la compañía en ocho dólares
ahora tenemos seis acciones que
representan algo que vale 12 dólares la
compañía no simplemente generó estas
acciones recibió cuatro dólares en
efectivo y no se puede debatir el valor
de cuatro dólares cuatro dólares son
cuatro dólares por lo que ahora tenemos
12 dólares de activos no tenemos pasivos
tenemos seis acciones 12 dólares
dividido entre 6 acciones sigue siendo 2
dólares por acción por lo que el valor
de la acción no se ha diluido solamente
el porcentaje de la compañía que cada
acción representa